in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Nick is
with us hi Nick how are you good Dave
how are you better than I deserve where
do you live sir
Britain's in Florida Orlando area that
close to Tampa cool all right right
between I guess huh so so uh welcome
you're here to do your debt-free screen
I am I love it and how much have you
paid off ninety one thousand three
hundred dollars in 73 months
Wow very cool making what kinda money I
started out about 1,300 a month and then
I ended about thirty one hundred a month
okay so you started about forty five
thousand and you ended about 38,000
thirty-nine thousand yeah between two
jobs so you went down yeah all right so
you started out 45 down to 38 and you
still paid off over a thousand dollars a
month making that Wow yeah did you sell
stuff I sold one car mm-hmm and that was
it what is sell for ten grand okay so
ten of the ninety one the rest of it
very good
so tell me about this journey 73 months
what got you started on this and what
did you do well I actually got myself in
some legal trouble because I why not
driving when I shouldn't have and at
that point they don't let you drive
anywhere I can drive to work and I can
wrap your church and the doctor
basically just like if I'm only able to
drive to work that's all I'm gonna do so
I picked up basically two full-time jobs
mm-hmm and I actually didn't hear about
you or the debt snowball or FPU until
almost four years into it mm-hmm and
then you can't preach to my church when
I started listening your podcast and
once it did that I then I jumped on the
debt snowball and picked up a lot of
steam that way okay cool which church
Bayside community Joe oh yeah absolutely
okay very cool so your life was in a
mission it sounds like you ended up in
church in the process yeah pretty much
very cool good for you good for you and
what kind of debt was the ninety one
thousand I was a little bit of
everything I had almost 20,000 cars
28,000 in credit cards I had some
medical bills legal bills you name it I
had it I was normal
what do you do for a living I work for
steel fabricator okay what do you do
auto cad work okay
good good for you and you're single I
take it yep okay
so what was the hardest part of this
whole process for you the how does about
definitely doing the repayment is uh
debt cost more than money especially
when you're paying it off it affects
every part of your life so for me you
know my social life got kill you don't
you don't got with your friends when you
work in 80 hours a week you know you
don't go to movies you don't date you
just you work and you go home and go to
bed basically so that was tough missing
out on all that stuff mm-hmm but worth
it in the end mm-hmm great place to go
when you're broke to work yeah yeah you
knew that you knew the answer to that
part of the equation and then about
halfway through the process you end up
running into us at your church very cool
good for you that's fun so what do you
tell people the secret to paying off
ninety one thousand dollars and seventy
three months is two things where the one
is attack it
you know don't mess around all that
don't let it sit around you know take a
spare bedroom as you like to say and
then the second things really follow
your plan for the like you said the
first four months for four years really
I was doing it my own way
the last half of this time I was making
almost 19% less when I was getting out
of debt 75% faster using your plan than
I was doing it on my own
Wow so stick to the plan why do you
think that was I think for me
specifically really controlling my
spending okay you know and I had this
idea like I want to get out of debt and
I was working hard but I wasn't really
cutting out the things I should have cut
out and then uh the path of how to do it
wasn't clear right and for and the debt
snowball too I was attacking you know
not maybe there's smallest bill I was
attacking stuff well if I pay this off
it'll take a biggest chunk out of my
monthly payments which didn't really
work that well
yeah well very cool yeah congratulations
dude how does it feel
that's awesome oh fat you got to feel
light it does it feels like freedom yeah
really I mean you got ninety one
thousand dollars off of your head ninety
one gram that's huge
yeah it's amazing well congratulations
I'm glad you said a life back and I'm
glad you got it back in order me too
happy for you good stuff good folks at
Bayside yep all right ninety one
thousand dollars paid off Nick from
Bradenton seventy three months it took
him making 45 down to 38 County
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one you saw that well done man
that's it that's it right there